what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe that you've got some insane
potential inside you that I want to see
burst out into the world to have a big
impact for you your family your
community and everybody around you so to
help you on your journey in today's
video I'm talking about seven ways to
improve your negotiation skills so
negotiating this part of being an
entrepreneur there's a lot of deals that
we have to work out with our customers
with our suppliers with our employees
with our investors
there's always deals that have to happen
and today I'm going to give you seven
ways to improve your negotiation skills
to get the best deal possible tip number
one is build emotional equity and this
actually happens before you sit down and
do the negotiation the more people know
you like you trust you feel like they
can connect with you besides just
getting to a meeting and sitting down
and getting right the business the
better the chances they're gonna give
you a good deal you're gonna work
something out I hate showing up to any
kind of negotiation and it's right to
business
I have no context on who they are we
don't know anything about each other and
so it can really help you get a really
great deal is to do the prep work in
advance try to get to know the person a
little bit more in advance try to help
them out with something that they're
working on in advance so you build up
your emotional equity with them so they
like you so they know you so they trust
you before you even walk into the room
and you position yourself for success
[Music]
number two is envision how the
conversation is going to go and so when
you get into a negotiation you never
quite know how everything's gonna play
out but I always have a game plan right
it's good to have a game plan going in
imagine what its gonna be like when you
sit down what you're gonna say what
topics are gonna cover how you generally
see a conversation going when you can
envision that in advance and it's not
just I I envisioned it so it's going to
happen it's important that you have some
kind of game plan going in and so what
I'll do before going into an important
negotiation even sitting down talking to
my instructors here at Toronto dance
salsa before going into a meeting with
any of them where we might be
negotiating something I've played out
the conversation a few times in my head
how do I want to start what questions do
I want to ask what are some likely
answers that will come back if they ask
me this what am I gonna say if they say
this what are we gonna say it doesn't
mean I'm gonna predict everything that
comes out you never will but being able
to roleplay a little bit at least with
yourself Alex loves role-playing with me
so he loves having somebody else to
roleplay against I love just like doing
it with myself I don't like role-playing
with somebody in front of me so like
whatever works for you but that idea of
playing out a scenario in advance
envisioning how the conversation might
go and what your answers and replies
would be can really really really help
so again before we even get to the
meeting you want to set yourself up for
success by envisioning how the
conversation is going to go and having a
game plan
[Music]
tip number three is listen this is so
important if you want to be a good
negotiator if you want to get what you
want
it also comes from helping the other
person get what they want and so it
starts by listening to really important
things about listening one you're
getting clues you're looking for what
they care about what they're really
valuing and trying to find a way to work
it out right if you go in with the
approach like I'm gonna win and they're
gonna lose that is not a fantastic
mindset you're looking for ways that you
can both win you're looking for ways to
get what you want and for them to get
what they want and in order to
understand what they want you have to
get it out of them you gotta listen
right did the expression of you have two
ears and one mouth for a reason right
you want to be listening listen listen
listen understand what they want the
side benefit of it too is that you're
building rapport right the more you
listen the more you're taking in the
information they're saying the more they
feel connected to you people like to
talk they like to talk about themselves
and so the more that you let them talk
about themselves the more than thinking
I like this person you know I'm like
vibe with this person this person gets
me right now you're really doing is
listening and so again the more you
build up that trust and confidence and
friendship the more like that they want
to want to do business to you and find
the deal that you guys can work towards
together so listen
[Music]
tip number four is know your outcome
it's really helpful for you to know what
it is that you want coming out of this
negotiation right so back to tip number
two about envision where the
conversation is gonna go have an
understanding of what you want out of it
it doesn't mean that that's exactly what
you're gonna get and maybe some new
opportunities getting covered along the
path but to go in knowing what it is
that you want what's the ideal case
scenario and then what would you settle
for like what is what is the minimum
case scenario that you want out of that
situation having that clear picture is
really really important so you can work
towards it you don't need to necessarily
lead with it right away say this is what
I want but to know in your head what it
is that your outcome is going to be and
then the figure out what a desired
outcome is for them and then try to find
a place for both of you to be able to
match because you'll be some things that
you really care about that they don't
care so much about and some things that
they really care about that you can live
with not having and so figuring out that
ideal outcome for both of you is where
the real negotiations win tip number
five is be flexible in your approach so
we know our outcome we're a little bit
stubborn on that like this is what we
need to get out of this deal but how we
get there might change right no matter
how much you plan no matter how much
you've you know worked in advance to try
to figure out how the conversations
gonna go there's still gonna be a lot of
twists and turns and if you are fix time
this is the only way to go out and get
this goal then it's gonna be really hard
to get a deal that works for both of you
right and so just like an
entrepreneurship you have a mission you
have a vision you have your values
you're stubborn on that like this is
this is the big thing I'm trying to
build but the how to get there the
execution can change can flow right
you're gonna have to go with what the
market wants and make adjustments along
the way the business plan that you have
never ends up being the business plan
that works but the vision that you have
is the one you're constantly working
towards and so same thing in negotiation
you have this goal you know what you
want this is your outcome you've
envisioned how the conversation will go
but how to get there will change and be
flexible and almost always almost always
at every negotiation I managed to bring
something out from somebody something
that they care about that wasn't on the
table before and that I can live with
right like
you're always gonna have price of money
as one of the variables and in most
negotiations but there's always other
things that people care about that you
may not care so much about and things
again that you care about that they may
not care so much about and that's what
you need to have the conversation to
unlock those things that they really
want that could add value to them that
for you is really easy to give up and so
as an example I was negotiating with
somebody who wanted to join my team and
really cared about their title right it
wasn't in the first discussion but they
really wanted to control what they
called themselves you know what their
position would be what the name would be
I don't care what them and you call it
call yourself chief Smurf I don't care
what you call yourself as also it's not
going super confusing I guess for the
brain right don't call yourself founder
or CEO or something but they wanted to
have a creative title for themselves and
that was important to them
I don't care call yourself whatever you
want right so just understanding that
makes them happy gives them something
take something off the table that really
gives them a win where for me it doesn't
make a difference and there'll be other
things that you want that have high
perceived value for you that they won't
care about right and so being able to
uncover as many of these things as
possible especially on their side like
you want your outcome this is what
you're trying to get there may be some
other wins you can bring out
understanding what they want and will
pay for and then giving them the other
things that have a high perceived value
to them but doesn't actually cost you
that much on your side and being
flexible in that approach can really
help you seal the deal and get a big win
[Music]
tip number six is believe in your
position a lot of times with
negotiations and conversations it's the
people who are most confident in the
position that wins if I'm certain that
I'm bringing a lot of value if I'm
certain that what I'm asking for is fair
and is right right if I have that level
of absolute belief uncertainty then I
will sway them I don't even need to use
specific words or convince them like you
need to listen to me right just my inner
belief that what I'm doing is worth it
and so many times especially the
entrepreneurs we tend to underprice
ourselves we tend to go into a
negotiation with a client as an example
and you're you're bidding on a project
and and it'll come in and say you know
this is worth $10,000 like you go in and
say I'm gonna charge $10,000 but if you
go insane it's gonna be $10,000 they
know it's not worth it
right they know that you're hesitate and
another you don't feel confident in your
work even though maybe the value you're
bringing is worth three times on amount
you're underpricing yourself because you
don't actually believe in the value of
your work and just believing in your
position you get what you believe you're
worth in life and in business and so if
you are going and asking for ten
thousand dollars but you believe you're
really worth three you're gonna get down
to three right and so having that
confidence in your position knowing that
this is what I'm worth knowing that
you're bringing a lot of value to them
without rubbing it in their face it's
not saying like I'm bringing you so much
fire alarm
so we just had a fire alarm here and
part of being an entrepreneur is rolling
with the punches just like in any good
negotiation and so understanding that I
believe what I'm worth this video is
worth this much what I'm bringing the
value proposition is worth this much
money and having confidence that this is
actually what you can bring is really
really really really really really
really really really important
[Music]
all right fire alarm is done let's keep
going
[Music]
tip number seven is be willing to walk
away no matter what negotiation you have
you need to figure out like I said
before your ideal outcome and what your
minimum requirement is gonna be and if
you don't hit that then you have to be
willing to walk away the strength comes
from the ability to walk away not as a
just a negotiation tactic and threaten
leaving its really strong if you
actually are going to walk away and
there gonna be some deals that you just
can't accept some deals that just maybe
they don't pay you enough some deals
that just the terms aren't good enough
you know as you build your business
there's a certain level you're not gonna
be able to take every single deal that
comes your way and so understanding what
your walkaway point is there are some
easy ones like if they if they're
against your value sometimes they might
pay you a lot of money but it's against
your values and you don't want to go off
and do that a lot of times I've run into
some deals where it just doesn't feel
right at the beginning you really want
it to work out just culturally what they
want and what you want just doesn't feel
right and you do it anyway and then you
regret it those deals don't take when
you get that gut feeling walk away don't
take it but in terms of the other terms
it doesn't have to be a threat it
doesn't have to be negative it doesn't
have to be yelling at them you have to
have at some point what your walkaway
break points gonna be if you don't hit
that minimum standard don't fall into
the trap of doing work that is below
what you feel is worth your time doing
and then you resent that person you
resent yourself you don't do a fantastic
job in a project know what your walkway
point is and stick to it
now one last bonus point that I want to
add on here is I think it's really
important to be careful who are you
negotiating with and also leaving
something on the table if I'm the
Gaussian around my internet package or
some giant corporation then I want to go
she try to get everything I can because
I know they don't care about me because
I know I'm never gonna talk to that
person again because I'm just a number
and I get lost in the shuffle
and so the go shake and get as big a
deal as you can when you're dealing with
giant corporations but when you deal
with entrepreneurs I'm really careful
and I always try to leave something on
the table for them I want them feeling
happy with the deal because I know that
that extra $100 or thousand
or whatever it's gonna be can be really
important to them and can make the
difference between them delivering a
fantastic project that they love and
they're really happy with or not and so
what I would hate to do is negotiate
somebody all the way down to the bone
right if you know entrepreneurs as an
example always on the price themselves
you use that to your advantage you get a
30% off deal and you've trapped them
into this box that then they're stuck in
and they resent it and they have to do
this work but they don't really want to
and they don't feel happy about the deal
that's not somebody who you want working
on your projects right like yes maybe
you got the best financial deal possible
but I want their hearts and their souls
into it as well not just their minds and
so I'm very careful when the Goshen with
entrepreneurs and smaller businesses not
to try to take everything try to leave
something on the table so everybody's
happy
and they are on board with what we're
trying to do so just be careful when
you're negotiating
pay close attention to who you're
dealing with it's about both of you
winning and not just you winning and
then losing so thank you guys so much
for watching I made this video because
Amanda aneema asked me to if there's a
topic you'd like me to cover in a future
seven ways video check out the link in
the description you can go to that video
and leave it in the comments what you
want me to talk about and I might just
make a video for you I'd also love to
know what did you take from this video
which lesson hits you the hardest so
you're gonna apply immediately somehow
to your next negotiation did I miss an
eight nine ten that you want to add to
the list share your thoughts down the
comments below I'm really excited to
hear from you I also want to give a
quick shout out to Dodie Dodie thank you
so much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word taking the picture posting
it to your online accounts I really
really appreciate support and I hope you
enjoyed the reading thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
I'll see you soon
[Music]
yeah the most important work ever if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
so it would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details